[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it was supposed to be
Trump's Katrina remember that it was a
full month of angry protests hysterical
columns shrieking media personalities
dishonest magazine covers all designed
to turn voters against the president
decisively and permanently the
immigration policies coming out of the
White House made Trump like Hitler they
told you that again and again and begin
on the other channels it was a month of
non-stop drama red-faced demagogues
barking into TV cameras progressive mobs
threatening administration officials in
restaurants things seem to fall apart
what was the effect of all of this
politically we now have a clues
conclusive answer to that in the first
week of June right before all this began
the president's approval rating
according to the Real Clear Politics
average was 42 percent his disapproval
rating was 54% that's a spread of 12
points after a full month of all the
cable news morons calling him Hitler
Trump's approval rating rose to 43%
that's one of the highest of his
presidency and his disapproval drops to
52 percent that's a spread of nine
points an improvement over the beginning
of the month but here's the remarkable
part in the Harvard Harris Poll the
president's approval rating rose 10
points among Hispanic voters keep in
mind is over the exact same period when
every single person with a master's
degree in the continent United States
was telling you that Trump hates
Hispanics and yet his number among
Hispanic voters rose 10 points amazing
could it be that the cable news dummies
don't really understand the country they
pretend to report on could it be that
Hispanic Americans are pretty much like
every other American normal people who
love their country and know that illegal
immigration hurts all of us it looks
that way that's bad news for Democrats
who are betting that a campaign of
hysteria and race baiting would move
voters to the polls on their behalf in
November it hasn't worked will left
figure out that it hasn't worked maybe
but maybe not
they've grown so confident that Trump is
finished overdone that they're no longer
hiding what they really think they
pulled off the mask and there
telling you directly calls to halt
family separation turned almost
immediately into demands to end
deportation itself to abolish ice
abolished profit abolish prisons the
left believes that voters are so angry
at Trump that they want to abolish the
country that elected him and replace it
with an entirely new country where
borders and business were the law itself
all no longer exist they're betting that
most voters hate Trump so much that
they've come to hate America too that's
their gamble as tonight it is not paying
off